The solution to this equation is x equals 3 over 26. If you got the answer
right, you are well on your way. Let's see how we got that answer. Once again,
this is an equation that has fractions in it. Since I don't want to have to add
and subtract, multiply and divide a lot of fractions, I can clear the fractions
by multiplying through by the least common denominator. The denominator are 6,
2, and 3. The least common denominator is 6. So, I have to multiply the equation
through by 6. I'm going to skip this step of showing the individual
multiplication of the terms. When I multiply 6 times x plus 7 over 6, the six is
cancelled out, and I'm left with x plus 7. When I multiply 6 times 1 half x, 6
times 1 half is 3, and I have to multiply that by x. When I multiply 6 times 2
3rds, I get 12 over 3, which is 4. Remember, when I'm multiplying through by the
least common denominator, I have to multiply the least common denominator by
every term. And that's every term whether there's a fraction in the term or not.
So, I also have to multiply 6 times 4x, which gives me 24x. Now that I've
eliminated all the fractions from my equation, I can combine my terms. On the
left side, I only have x plus 7. And on the right side, I have 3x plus 24x is
going to give me 27x. And then, I have the plus 4. The next thing I want to do
since I like to deal with positive coefficients is to subtract x from both
sides. Even though there's not a coefficient in front of this x, we know that
there's a 1 there. So, 1x minus 1x gives me 0 and the only thing I have left on
the left side of the equation is 7. On the right side of the equation, I have
27x minus 1x, gives me 26x plus 4. No that my variable is on one side of the
equation, I want to isolate it by subtracting 4 from both sides of the equation.
7 minus 4 is 3 and that equals 26 x. The last step is to divide both sides of
the equation by the coefficient of the variable, which is 26. When I do that, I
know 26 over 26 is 1, so I have x on the right side of the equation and 3 over
26 on the left side of the equation. Remember, it doesn't matter whether you
have a number equals x or x equals a number. It's the same thing.
Congratulations on completing solving linear equations. Now that you've learned
how to solve linear equations, let's do something a little bit different. Chris,
what do you have up for us next?